so Emily what do you do at Khan Academy
I am a biology content fellow here and
what does that mean that means that I am
coming from a biology background I used
to do biology research and now I'm sort
of trying to bring that knowledge to
expand what we already have on Khan
Academy to cover even more of biology
and used to be more than just about me
you have a PhD in yes yeah in plant
molecular biology if you want to get
really specific and so what does it mean
that kind of helping us develop like
what's your day-to-day like here at Khan
Academy so I spent a little bit
different over the time that I've been
here but it's been a lot of sort of
going through what we already have for
biology going through textbooks aligning
the videos that we already have and
seeing what gaps we've got that we want
to maybe create new material for or you
know find something even more targeted
for particular areas and and what what I
guess brought you here
that's a great question it was a lot of
serendipity you know I was sort of
finishing my PhD and I was interested in
education I really liked biology wasn't
sure what to do and I kind of stumbled
onto a cotton Academy's website I never
heard of it before I was like oh this is
amazing but they don't have as much
biology as they have of math you know I
should write to them okay and it was
within a month of that that the job
opening was posted so the rest is
history I guess or biology and and and
what about kind of your goals for like
the next you know what are you hoping to
get done here I would love to see sort
of a really awesome library of high
quality fun bio material that basically
covers what an intro textbook would
cover but not in a textbook II way you
know in a way that is much more
accessible and you know students would
go to it not just cuz they have to learn
the material because they're also going
to enjoy interactive
and what is you know you have I guess
you have a PhD in biology you're now
here at kind of what advice would you
have for someone one who's either just
trying to learn about biology thinking
about a PhD or they kind of want to do
what you're doing now gosh I mean I
think that really I would just say to
like try to follow whatever it is that
really grabs you in biology you know you
can never go wrong if you're thinking
about something and you just go wow
that's so beautiful that's so cool I
want to go understand that more or I
want to go share that with people I mean
as long as you really have that passion
for it I think it can lead you a lot of
places you wouldn't expect to be I never
expected you know this is where I would
end up but you know it's it's been great
and I think that you know you can find
yourself in unexpected places if you
just really go for that sort of beauty
what was your moment where you said I
want to you know biology is where my
passion is for me that was very much
about having an awesome professor well
an awesome teacher in high school and an
awesome professor at the intro level in
college so I just got really lucky that
I had two people who taught biology so
that it was exciting it was really
systematic it fit together like this
really cool little puzzle and I think
the key moment was probably when I was a
freshman in college and I took my first
bio seminar course and we had to read
papers and I was terrified and I went to
my professor almost in tears I can't do
this I you know I should just drop the
class and she wouldn't let me she was
just like no you can do this you're
really good and that ended up the topic
of that seminar ended up being my
specialty for the next decade basically
so which is a huge I mean a lot of times
in life you you're in those moments you
could have quit and then you prot only
you would have done something else I'm
sure but now not only did you engage and
you overcame but that became your
specialty yeah I became your passion
was a very definitive moment as it
turned out so you actually found yeah
well and and what you know what you've
been here it kind of counted me for a
little bit now I mean what has surprised
you about it that's a great question I
think I mean what surprised me the most
is just how much you get to interact
with all different kinds of people and
how it's actually really
cross-functional and collaborative that
way and maybe that's not a surprise to
people who come here from big companies
but coming here from a lab most big
companies are optimally functional and
they're just like smooth running
machines everyone's very happy I guess I
just I interacted with great people in
my old job but everybody was a
researcher and it's been really cool to
meet people who are developers and
people who are strategy and people who
are you know donor partnerships or
school partnerships and you get a lot of
really different perspectives and you
see how you end up at really different
places when you bring all of those
perspectives to one project so I guess
that's that's been just really
interesting and cool for me and I feel
like I've learned a lot just from
osmosis being around those people
there's no pun intended
down the bio terminology using the
analogy through diffusion is not smooth
and what are you excited about I am I'm
really excited about sort of the new
stuff that we're starting to make for
biology and I'm excited about you know
seeing what its gonna look like seeing
who we're going to have making it you
and me
perhaps participating a lot but also you
know trying to get other people who are
really passionate about it who have a
lot of expertise and just you know
seeing what super cool stuff we're gonna
have I'm really excited that ball is
rolling I'm excited as well and thank
you so much for being part of this my
pleasure